This is episode one of the Warrior Kid podcast.
Ask Uncle Jake.
Good Morning Eco.
Good morning.
And we're putting that together,
this podcast for kids.
This is a podcast for kids specifically.
This is a podcast for warrior kids,
uh,
based on the book,
the way of the warrior kid.
And we're going to talk about that book and basically answer a bunch of
questions that a bunch of kids asked.
So first of all,
really quickly,
if you don't know anything about the warrior kid,
don't know who uncle Jake is,
don't know who I am and don't know who echo is really quickly.
My name is Jocko Willink.
I was born and raised in a little new England town on a dirt road and I joined
the navy when I was 18 years old and I went into the seal teams and I stayed in
the seal teams for 20 years.
I had a great time.
I love my job.
I worked with a bunch of great people,
people that were in the seal teams,
people in the army,
people in the navy,
people in the air force and the Marine Corps.
I fought in the war in Iraq and it was an honor to be there with so many brave
men and women.
And I eventually retired from the navy.
And now I have a business where I teach people about leadership and I live out
here in California and I have four kids in my own now,
uncle Jake,
he's one of the characters in the book way,
the Warrior Kid.
And a lot of people think uncle Jake is me.
But that is actually not true.
Uncle Jake is a fictional character,
which means he isn't real and it,
but even though he's not real in real life,
he's real in my head.
So when I wrote about him,
it was very easy for me to write about him because I kind of knew what he was
like.
He's uncle Jake is kind of the seal that I always tried to be uncle Jake's
better than me.
He's the the ideal seal,
meaning that he has the characteristics that I think the best seal would be
like.
And I was certainly not the best seal.
I tried my best,
but it's a hard job.
And even though I don't know,
even though I'm not quite as good as uncle Jake is in many respects in many
respects,
not even close.
But I do know how he thinks and that's why I think I'll be able to answer some
of the questions that people had for uncle Jake.
And then lastly,
Echo Charles.
He is a friend of mine from Jujitsu who is really good with computers and video
cameras and voice recorders and he helps make all these podcasts.
And the reason that we know each other is from training Jujitsu,
which has been trending for a long time and Jujitsu and that's how we know each
other.
And he has two little warrior kids of his own.
How old are they?
Echo currently?
Nine months.
And for years,
you know,
little kids,
one girl and one boy.
I have three girls and one boy and my oldest girl is about to graduate from high
school and my youngest daughter is in second grade.
So that's my,
that's who I am.
And like I said,
this is a podcast for kids and you all sent a bunch of questions and I
definitely appreciate it.
I appreciate that you all,
you kids put pictures of yourselves doing a bunch of things that are good for
you.
Reading a book,
which is awesome.
You sent pictures of you doing pull ups,
doing pushups,
studying,
making times tables,
all those things and,
and I really enjoyed seeing all these kids doing all those things that are good.
A lot of times you hear about kids doing things that are bad and that this was a
complete opposite of that kid's doing things that were good.
So I got a bunch of questions and I'm going to just try and answer them as quick
as I can.
Thank you for asking them.
So here we go.
I'm going to get right into it.
Nathan wanted to know when the next war your kid's book is coming.
It's coming in May of 2018
benedict wanted to know how many books I have and how many I've read already.
I have a lot of books.
I don't know the number,
but I have a lot of books.
I read books all the time and when I went to college,
I actually studied English,
which means I read even more books.
I didn't keep all those books.
I kept some of them,
the ones that I liked,
I kept the ones that I didn't like.
I got rid of him.
And,
but right now I would say I have a few hundred books and I've read probably a
little bit,
well probably around half of them.
Some of them I only referred to.
But yeah,
the more you read,
the smarter you get.
So keep reading.
Next,
how does a seven year old deal with bullying,
physical bullying and being left out of groups?
So this is the best way I think you'd deal with bullying.
Do pullups that's one thing.
Do Jujitsu,
study,
learn,
read.
And with all those things,
the better you get at those things,
the more confident you'll be,
then the more confident you are,
the less bullying occurs.
Now,
sometimes you're gonna get bullied.
Everybody's going to get bullied.
I got bullied when I was a kid.
It happens.
There's always,
and I and I even see adults that get bullied,
eve,
it's not quite the same,
but some people have a boss that's a bully or they're in a relationship with a
girlfriend or a boyfriend or a husband and wife and they can be bullies.
So bullying happens all the time and you,
you got to learn to deal with it.
But some of the best things you can do is try and make yourself better by
working out,
by studying,
by learning.
And those things will help you gain confidence.
And when you gain confidence,
there's less bullying.
Now as far as being left out of groups,
that's not that big of a deal because you know what?
It's okay to be alone sometimes.
And if there's some people that are out there that don't want to hang around
with,
you,
find some other people to hang around with.
And if there's no one to hang around with,
that's okay to go hang around with a book,
go hang around with a pullup bar.
That's okay.
It's not always fun,
but sometimes that's the way it has to be.
Sometimes there's no kids around that are interested in the same things as you,
so that's no big deal.
All right,
next question.
Do you get a lot of alleys,
uncle Jake?
Well,
yes,
I do get some alley sometimes.
Well,
uncle Jake rarely gets hurt.
Jocko.
Me,
I get hurt sometimes.
Right now I have a broken knuckle,
which is bothering me.
I cut my foot last night for no reason,
which is bothering me and I have tweaked me.
That's what's going on with,
with Jocko right now.
Uncle Jake gets hurt a little less than Jocko,
but everyone get hurt.
Everyone's a human.
And who taught uncle Jake to be a war?
Your kid when he was four years old.
And those questions are from Zacky.
We're going to get into into uncle Jake and how he grew up.
But uncle Jake wasn't born a warrior.
He wasn't born a warrior kid.
He had to become a warrior kidney,
kind of talks about that in the book.
He couldn't do a bunch of pushups before he joined the military.
He couldn't do a bunch of punks.
He had to learn.
He didn't know to be smart.
He had to learn how to study.
So we'll talk about that and some of the future warrior kid books.
Next up,
how often could you have a treat without falling for the sugarcoated lies?
And that's from Durham,
age 11 sometimes you can have treats for sure and you just have to make sure
that you're not going overboard and going crazy with the snickers bars.
And the Cheetos Echo knows that that I eat Cheetos sometimes.
Yes,
they have bags of Cheetos in our,
in our office where we record this.
And so sometimes I grab a bag of Cheetos and the thing is you just gotta be
careful that you don't go overboard with stuff.
So if you want to have an occasional,
make sure they earn it.
That's one thing I like to do is I like to make sure that I earn it,
meaning I'm going to work out hard before I delve into the sugarcoated lies.
Just be careful.
Good way to look at that.
And Holly,
go over it with my daughter is things like Cheetos and m and m's and all these
things.
They,
you weak other
fruits make you strong.
So yeah,
if you eat a bunch of strong foods,
if you had some Cheetos,
sure it's gonna make you weaker,
but you'll still be strong overall.
So it gives them an idea,
you know,
of like eating a bunch of strong food,
you're still gonna maintain that strongness.
Right,
right.
And then,
okay,
so every once in a while you can have some weak foods,
but you'll still be strong.
The more weak foods you have,
the weaker you're going to get.
Yes.
And you don't want to let the weak foods be more than the strong foods because
then you're going to be weak instead of being strong or even even because you
eat a bunch of strong foods,
you get all strong and then you eat a bunch of weak foods,
then now you're back to zero.
Yeah.
We don't want to be zero.
No,
we don't.
All right.
Levi at sent a video question that was pretty funny.
Uh,
and a good question.
How many pull ups,
push ups,
sit ups,
burpees should I be able to do by the end of summer?
And I had asked him back,
how many can you do right now?
And he said he could do five pull ups,
14 four 36 setups.
And he didn't know how many burpees.
And so I answered him back and said he should try for 12 pullups 35 pushups,
60 setups and 30 burpees into minutes.
And he said,
thanks for helping with this exercises.
So that's something that every one's going to want to know is how many should I
be able to do?
Well,
it's as many as you can and you're always working to try and get one more.
That's what I'm always doing.
So if you can do for hopefully next week you can do five.
Once you can do five,
hopefully the week after that you can do six new.
You're always trying to build and get stronger.
And what's really nice about being a kid is it's a,
you're able to keep getting stronger and stronger and stronger for years and
years and years.
Once you're an old man like me,
then it's harder to make those gains.
Yeah.
But that's okay.
We still keep working cause otherwise we start going backwards.
Yeah.
And we don't want to do that.
No.
Next One from Colin,
I'm 14,
so I guess I'm still considered a kid.
Loved to know what would happen if you ever took a day off from your routine.
I guess he means by my routine,
it's working out and getting up early.
And if that happened,
you know,
I would just have to get back on the routine the next day.
And I think what you have to watch out for is you take a day off.
Okay.
And then that turns into two days off and then that turns into a week and then
that turns into a month.
And then the next thing you know,
you've been off your routine and you're getting,
you're not getting stronger,
you're getting weaker,
you're not getting smarter,
you're getting dumber.
You don't want that.
Uh,
you beat next one.
You beat the sun up every morning.
What time do you go to sleep?
And how important is rest and nutrition to a warrior kid?
Rest and nutrition.
Nutritionist really important.
And you should sleep all lot.
That's what makes you recover.
That's what helps you grow,
especially kids that are still growing.
You need to get as much sleep as you can,
so go to bed.
I'll tell you when you go to bed,
go to bed when you feel tired.
And a lot of times this these days,
that means putting away the iPhone and the iPad and stuff that keeps you awake
for no reason.
Put those things away and go to sleep.
Cause when you're going to sleep,
you're getting stronger.
Next one,
my little warrior wants to know if all kids have to train Brazilian Jujitsu.
Are there other options?
She's in another sport for 10 hours a week.
While the most important thing,
and that's great,
is that she's training and she's training hard and there's all kinds of sports
in all sports are good for you and it's good to train hard and sports and it's
good to focus on sports so you don't have to train Jujitsu to be a warrior.
That being said,
if you get the chance,
try and take a little Jujitsu and I'll tell you why.
Because one thing that Jujitsu will give you that other sports won't give you as
the means to defend yourself and stand up for yourself if someone's picking on
you or bullying you.
So it is important to train Jujitsu,
but if you're training really hard and other athletics,
you might not be able to do as much as you want.
Um,
but that's okay.
Just try and squeeze in a little bit so you know how to take care of yourself
and defend yourself.
Good for autonomy as well.
So like if you play team sports,
it,
there is this element,
this is a good thing by the way,
that we're,
people are depending on you to do your job.
You're depending on other people to do their jobs.
So you can collectively win in Jujitsu or track,
which there's a small element of that.
But mainly it's the,
it's you,
you,
you have to go in,
you have to take it upon yourself to get the job done for you.
And it's,
it's essentially all all I knew.
And you learn that.
So if you play team sports the whole time,
you get less of that.
You have a law there.
Is that in team sports?
For sure,
but it's more prevalent than the Jujitsu or wrestling or track something where
you're,
it's just you,
just to you.
Yeah,
those are,
those are good sports.
Very intense,
very intense sports.
And you,
like I said,
you learn how to defend yourself.
Next one.
Bennett from Michigan wants to know Uncle Jake.
Why did you want to be a navy seal?
Well,
Uncle Jake always wanted to be some kind of commando ever since he was a little
kid and as soon as he figured out what the seal teams were,
that's what he,
that's what he decided to go for.
Next one.
Uncle Jake,
my son Mccoy wants to know when you will have your own TV show.
I don't know.
But we do have right now the first warrior kid podcast,
so we'll see what happens with the TV show.
I would rather have a bunch of kids reading books rather than watching a TV show
next.
Anderson turns eight today and asks what would win karate or Jujitsu
and the answer to that question is Jujitsu.
Actually that's been gone over a bunch of times now.
There's a bunch of good stuff you get from karate to,
you learned a lot about discipline and karate.
You learn some good striking in karate,
so that's good too.
But if he can try and train some Jujitsu as well so that you learned some
grappling.
It's a different type of fighting and when you put pure striking,
which is punching and kicking each other against pure grappling,
most of the time it's the grappler that wins.
Next one.
How do you be a warrior?
Well,
talk about that a lot in the way of the warrior kid book and Uncle Jake explains
too.
He explains to mark exactly.
Well,
kind of not exactly,
but he explains to them what a war your kid is.
Any,
any explains to him in a pretty good paragraph.
I just opened up the book.
Here's what,
here's what a warrior kid is.
A normal kid doesn't push himself.
A warrior kid does.
A normal kid doesn't work constantly trying to improve himself.
A warrior kid does all these problems that you cried about yesterday,
mark,
a warrior kid wouldn't cry about those problems.
A warrior kid would do something about those problems.
So those are some of the things that a warrior kid does also.
And if you read though the code that Mark writes at the end of the book of what
it's like to be a warrior and his,
he makes his own warrior kid code that he's going to live by,
that the rules that he's going to have.
And those are very good rules to be a warrior.
And I think,
I think mark did a great job of of coming up with those rules and I'll tell you
what they are.
Number one,
the warrior kid wakes up early in the morning.
Number two,
the warrior kids studies to learn and gain knowledge and asks questions if he
doesn't understand.
Number three,
the warrior kid trains hard exercises and eats right to be strong and fast and
healthy.
Number for the warrior kid trains know how to fight so he can stand up to
bullies and protect the week.
Number five the warrior kid treats people with respect and helps out other
people whenever possible.
Number six,
the warrior kid keeps things neat and is always prepared and ready for action.
Number seven,
the warrior kid stays humble.
Number Eight,
the warrior kid works hard and always does his best.
Number nine I am the warrior kit,
so
that's what
being a warrior is,
especially for a kid.
Next,
hi Uncle Jake.
My name is Chris.
I'm eight years old.
I go to Jujitsu class every week.
How can I get better?
The bigger kids always beat me.
Well,
that's what happens in the beginning of Jujitsu.
When you first start off Jujitsu,
you get beat all the time.
It happened to me when I was starting Jujitsu and it happens to everyone.
When they start Jujitsu,
you get beat and the way that you get better is by keeping training,
keep training all the time,
as much as you can,
and that's how you get better.
And eventually what's good about Jujitsu is when you know more Jiu Jitsu than
the other person,
you can still beat them even if they're bigger than you.
So that's why I really liked Jujitsu.
Next,
my son wants to know why no matter what the situation or problem mark has,
Uncle Jake always says good.
So the reason that uncle Jake always says good when there's a problem is because
you always look at things in the most positive light.
And when he sees things,
other people might see something as a problem.
He sees that as a challenge that he can overcome.
And that's why when he sees a problem,
he just says,
good,
let's find a solution to that problem.
Next.
Hi Uncle Jake,
my nephew Lincoln is a military kid.
Second grader loves your book.
What would uncle Jake tell Lincoln about being sad when his friends move away?
Okay,
so when your friend friends move away,
one thing that's good is that when they're moving away all you,
you can still talk to him,
you can write them letters,
you can write them emails.
So it's no problem when friends move away.
And then the other thing that's good about when friends move away is it gives
you opportunity to make new friends.
So go shake some hands with some new kids and get to know them
next.
Would you ever consider making this book into a movie
and is there ever going to be a part two?
Yes,
there's going to be a part two
a movie that's not for me to decide.
I'm sure someone will want to make it into a movie can make it into a cool
cartoon.
Maybe a cartoon.
We'll have to see.
Rebecca asks,
what time should a nine year old get up?
And first of all,
you need to go to bed early enough that you get plenty of sleep and then you
need to get up early enough in the morning that you are ready for the day.
And if you're going to try and do some kind of exercise in the morning,
got to get up a little bit earlier and if you need to get up and do some extra
studying,
you got to get up a little bit earlier.
So you know,
get up early enough that you can have a good start to the day.
That's what you want to do
next.
What is your,
what is uncle Jake's favorite gun to shoot?
Uncle Jake's favorite gun to shoot is the 50 caliber machine gun,
which is a big heavy machine gun and it's very fun to shoot.
Next.
Jackson from Ohio says,
asked Uncle Jake,
how can I be a better gentleman?
It's a great question and the answer to that is treat people how you would like
to be treated.
So if you follow that rule and that basically boils down to a word that we use
called respect.
You treat people with respect.
In other words,
you treat them how you would like to be treated.
That's a great way to be on the path to becoming a better gentlemen.
Next,
would uncle Jake have treated the kid the same if mark was a girl or would he
have led up?
Well,
the answer to that is uncle Jake would've done the same
treated if mark was a girl and her name was Marsha instead of mark,
Uncle Jake.
What has done the same thing taught Marsha how to do pull ups.
Top Marsha,
how to study taught Masha how to defend herself.
All the problems that mark has in the book are the same.
I have three girls that as as kids,
three girls and one boy,
they all have had the same problems.
So uncle Jake would have done the same thing and and it says,
would he have led up and the answer's no.
Uncle Jake would not have led up because that wouldn't have helped her.
Okay,
next I'm eating good.
But any tricks or tips to eat faster?
It's an interesting question.
In the military you learn to eat very fast.
First of all,
there's no reason to eat faster.
You can take your time and it's probably better to take your time when you eat.
If you are taking too much time,
you're probably doing something else while you're eating,
like talking.
So stop talking and eat.
My daughters asked if mark in the book is named after Mark Lee.
Yes.
Mark Lee was a seal that was worked with me in Iraq and he was killed in Iraq
and yes,
mark and the book is named after Mark Lee.
It's another way for me to make sure people remember mark
next.
What can a kid say if kids use too much social media to convince their words to
limit use in their free time?
Well,
if your friends are using too much social media,
I think what you want to say to him is,
hey,
let's go play some basketball.
Let's go do some pull ups.
Let's go wrestle.
Let's go do some Jujitsu.
Let's go find bugs in the yard.
Let's put that computer screen away and let's go get better.
That social media stuff is not making you a better person.
Next nine year old girl that struggles to make friends at school and sometimes
feels left out.
Well,
like I said earlier,
it's hard for people to make friends and sometimes the people that are around
aren't going to be the best friends with you and that's okay.
I know different grades that I had,
different classes that I had.
I didn't always have a bunch of friends in them.
Sometimes it was hard to get along with people.
Sometimes they were interested in things that I wasn't interested in.
And what I would do in those times is just find something that I am interested
in and I would go and do it.
So if you're having trouble making friends,
go find a book,
read a book,
go look at what they're doing.
Maybe they're playing a game that you haven't played before and you're a little
bit shy about getting involved in it.
Don't be shy about it.
Walk over and say,
Hey,
can someone teach me that?
Can someone helped me learn this?
And if you open up the conversation,
if they're nice to you,
maybe you make a new friend.
If they're not,
try and find someone else that maybe is doing something else that you could be
interested in.
So I think a lot of times kids,
when you're a kid,
and I know I felt this way when I was a kid,
you feel like you should always have people around.
And if you,
if you're alone,
maybe it's not a good thing,
but it's okay.
It's okay to be alone.
It's okay to spend some time by yourself.
You don't always need friends everywhere.
It's friends are great and it's great when you make them,
but you can't force people to be your friends.
So I always found it comfortable or comforting that if I was by myself,
I was okay with it.
I don't feel bad about it.
Next,
how can I,
this is from Benjamin.
How can I discipline myself to work out every day and I have a lot of adults ask
me this question too,
and you know how you discipline yourself to work out every day.
You discipline yourself to work out every day.
There's no magic trick.
It's not easy.
You get up and you work out and you do it every day.
That's how you do it.
No magic trick there.
What kind of workout routine for mark and pull up program?
Well,
what if you want to do Paul,
if you want to get good at pull ups,
the best thing to do is pull ups.
You do lots of pullups.
If,
if you have a choice between doing sprints and long runs,
I like to do sprints more.
So all of these things,
you know,
don't get caught up around kids.
Don't get caught up around doing some specific program.
That's what your parents are all concerned about.
I want to get told the program to do what you do is you just do a bunch.
You do eight sets.
A set is when you get on the pull up bar and you do as many as you can do that
eight times.
Do it 10 times,
do it four times,
do it six times and then do as many pushups as you can and do that three or four
times,
maybe five times.
So don't get caught up on the program.
Just go do some stuff.
It's not that hard.
It's,
well,
I shouldn't say it's not that hard.
It's can be hard when you start working out and you're going to get tired and
stuff,
and that's one of the thing that you do need to do when you get tired,
go a little bit more.
That's what working out is.
When you get tired,
go a little bit more.
So go.
Do you know I like to say eight to 10 sets of pullups.
Eight to 10 sets of pushups.
Do some squats,
do some burpees.
One thing that's good with burpees is do as many burpees as you can in two
minutes.
See how,
see how many you can do.
Do that.
Do that every few days.
Maybe do that.
Do that on Tuesdays and Thursdays.
Many burpees as you can in two minutes
on the other days.
Do some pushups.
Next.
What should middle school,
young men,
ages 11 to 13 be working on to prepare to become a productive young man?
Hmm.
Well,
these are really easy to answer.
Study,
learn,
learn as much as you can.
Work,
work hard,
workout.
Be Nice to people,
make friends
read.
Those are the kinds of things you do.
The other question about social media,
that's not gonna help you become a productive young man.
What made you know what you wanted to do in life?
So like I said earlier,
Uncle Jake,
he always wanted to be a commando.
Next,
my kid cares about other kids.
Even the bullies,
he doesn't tattle but doesn't stick up for himself.
How can he grow confidence and courage again,
people want to grow.
Confidence and courage.
Confidence and courage don't grow on trees.
Confidence and courage grow from work,
from working,
from working out,
from studying,
from learning,
from participating in sports.
That's where you get confidence and courage from.
So try it.
All those things out.
A four year old girl says,
how are you doing uncle Jake?
Uncle Jake is doing really good right now.
And a six year old boy says,
did any of your friends die in the navy?
And yes,
Uncle Jake lost some friends,
very close friends while he was in the seal teams.
That's part of being in the military.
In the military,
you're job is to fight a war and in war people die and it's very sad and very
tragic.
And also it's the job of the soldiers and sailors and airmen and Marines to go
out and fight.
Next.
Uncle Jake,
how long his uncle Jake been in the navy and the book,
Uncle Jake has been in the navy for eight years.
When he goes to stay at his sister's house,
who's marksman
nine year old son or want to know if uncle Jake,
everyone to quit during training?
No.
Uncle Jake never wanted to quit
and a nine year old girl says,
how can I get over not doing things perfectly?
I get so frustrated when I don't do something perfect.
Oh,
that happens to a lot of people.
And what you do with that is you have to
realize that wanting things to be perfect is imperfect.
You're not perfect if you want everything to be perfect.
And also,
if you're trying to do everything perfect,
you'll never get anything truly done because you can't do anything perfectly in
the world.
So look to be looked to do a great job.
Look to do an outstanding job.
Look to do an excellent job.
But when you're going for perfection,
it's going to be too hard to do.
Next.
How does mark work on self awareness and frustration outside of Brazilian
Jujitsu?
Well,
when you get frustrated,
you have to realize,
you have to realize the things that you do when you start getting frustrated.
So if you start tensing up your arms or you start gritting your teeth or you
start getting tears in your eyes,
you have to realize what's happening.
Yo,
those tears in your eyes or just frustration and the,
and when you start getting all red in the face,
that's just frustrations.
So what you have to do is realize that you're getting frustrated and then take a
step back,
take a deep breath,
think about something else,
relax so that you don't let that frustration take over your brain.
Next
eight year old girl asks,
was Uncle Jake bullied?
Or a wimp like mark?
And the answer is yes.
Okay,
all little kids are getting bullied.
It happens.
It happens to a well.
It happens to just about it or maybe not every single kid in the world,
but most kids get bullied.
Especially when you're 10 years old.
When you're 10 years old,
there's always going to be somebody that's bigger and stronger than you.
And you know anyone that's 12 years old is bigger than you.
They're stronger than you.
There are even a lot of times smarter than you because they've learned a little
bit more.
Next
is echo gonna make any movies about mark?
He made one little short movie about mark.
I don't know.
I don't know what's going to happen with that.
We'll definitely make more books about mark
every okay kid Lucas that wants to be a seal.
Same answer you want to be a seal with.
The advice is study hard,
work hard,
train hard,
be a good kid,
don't get in trouble.
Do the best you can in school.
Play some sports.
Study hard.
That's it.
Okay.
The,
this boy is three and a half years old and wants to take Jujitsu,
but the school doesn't allow it until six years old.
So the question is should he go and watch or take kid karate?
What do you suggest?
I would say definitely let him come watch maybe once a week.
Just let him go there and be on the mats and see what it's like.
And then the after they've got a karate kid that if they've got a karate program
that he can get into until he could start to Jitsu,
I think that'd be good for him.
So what wrestling,
a lot of times if you can find wrestling,
they start a little bit younger.
And same thing with judo.
Maybe you can find a judo program.
They start them a little bit younger.
I would do wrestling first,
then judo second,
and then do those when he's younger,
until he can get old enough for Jujitsu.
How do you stand up to a bully?
It's all in the book way of the Warrior Kid.
You got to train hard,
you gotta work hard,
you got to be in good shape,
you've,
and then you got to stand your ground and guess what?
It doesn't mean you're going to win.
You might not win.
I got beat.
I know this is Jocko.
Jocko got beat up when we're not that.
I got my first fight,
I got beat and I got put in a headlock,
taken down to the ground.
I think I was in fourth grade and taken down to the ground,
held in the headlock and punched in the head.
Luckily it didn't last too long because the teachers were,
were pretty close.
So I stood up to the bully and I got taken down and put in a headlock and
punched in the head.
You know what though?
I didn't die and I felt good about it.
I was okay with getting punched in the head.
And a lot of times bullies,
you know,
just like in the book bullies,
the reason they're a bully is because they're mean and,
but no one ever challenges them.
So once they get challenged,
a lot of times they will back down.
Can you teach me to face my fears?
Well,
again,
we have things that we're afraid of.
We're afraid of them because we don't understand them.
So prepare as much as you can,
do as much as you can to get ready for that thing that you fear.
And then when you've practiced,
the thing that you fear the final step you have to do just like in the book
because you have to step.
You have to,
you have to go for it.
That's what you eventually have to do.
Can you teach me how to recognize things that aren't good like poison ivy and
stuff that's from Emma?
These questions were all from Emma.
Yeah.
Emma,
I can't teach you because I'm on a podcast right now,
but luckily there's so many good books out there and you can make little
flashcards just like mark doesn't.
The book with pictures of all the bad stuff out there in nature and that way you
know what poison ivy looks like.
Let's see.
Most important thing about being a warrior kid.
I think the most important thing about being a warrior and the warrior kid is to
be humble and to be humbled means you don't think you're the best thing in the
world.
We shouldn't think that.
The minute that you think that you aren't trying to get better anymore,
you weren't trying to improve yourself.
You're treating people poorly because you think you're better than them.
So there's a key word,
it's called humility and you always want to stay humble.
11 year old that wants to go towards a goal of being a seal.
Same thing.
Work hard.
Workout,
study hard.
Okay.
Favorite Brazilian Jujitsu move for Uncle Jake.
What do you think uncle Jake's favorite Brazilian Jujitsu move is?
I think it's the rear naked choke.
I haven't confirmed this yet.
And Uncle Jake joined the navy after he got done with high school.
He was 18 years old.
Oh Lucas wants to be a seal or a ranger,
but he has a hard time controlling his temper and following orders from his
superior.
Uncle Jake would say that in the seal teams and in the Rangers,
if you have a bad temper,
you're not going to make it.
So what you,
and you know what a lot of kids have bad tempers.
I had a bad temper when I was a kid and at some point you got to realize that
that bad temper is not good.
And so what you have to do is learn to control your temper.
So it's what I talked about earlier.
If you start feeling that temper,
if start feeling your face getting red and you start feel most tears coming in
your eyes,
you gotta say to Yourself,
Oh,
I'm losing my temper.
I'm actually being weak right now by losing my temper.
So what I'm gonna do is I'm going to take a breath,
I'm going to step back,
I'm going to calm down.
Even if you have to walk away and go in your room for a minute and just sit down
and take a breath and get control of your temper.
And the older you get,
the better you'll get at controlling your temper.
And then his follow as far as following orders from your superiors in the
military,
seal teams,
rangers,
you absolutely have to listen to the people that you work for.
And it's the same thing in the civilian sector.
So a good way to to practice that is by listening to what your parents say.
Now,
you might not think what your parents say,
you might not feel like doing it.
You might not feel like cleaning your room.
So it's good practice to look at your dad when he says to clean your room and
say,
no problem dad.
I got it.
That's good practice for when you get in the military.
Now you should also have a conversation with your dad and say,
Hey dad,
why is this important?
And have them explain it to you so that way you're more of a team than just your
dad barking orders at you.
Once you understand why it's important,
that will help you get motivated to do the job that's in front of you.
We got a bunch of questions from a guy named Mike Hurley.
Mike Kerley from,
he's a teacher,
so I'm going to have to go through these pretty pretty quickly.
First one is from,
I think this one's from Mike as well.
How'd you get the idea of writing way of the warrior kid?
A lot of the kids books that I read from my own kids,
I didn't like him very much.
Do I have any new books coming out?
The new book is coming out in May of 2018 favorite book I have written while
I've only written two books so far,
one is called way of the warrior kid,
which is for kids and the other one is called extreme ownership,
which is for adults and I like them both.
Did I relate to mark when I was younger?
Yes.
I think that's one of the reasons why this book is so popular is because
everyone can relate to mark.
There's no one that woke up and in and they were new when they were 10 years
old.
They were the best at everything.
No,
everyone has problems with different things.
What inspired me to become an author,
I wanted to kind of teach some of the lessons that I had learned.
Let's see.
Kay asks how to improve your grades in math,
how to improve your marks.
You've got to study.
That's the thing.
Just like just like,
just like mark in the book.
He didn't study is timestables and therefore he didn't know them.
So make your flashcards and study.
And then the other big thing that I learned from being in the navy is when you
don't understand something,
you have to ask the question in class,
you have to ask your teacher.
You know why you don't want to ask it because you're embarrassed because you
feel a fool.
If I asked this question,
that means I'm stupid and people will laugh at me.
It's not true.
And even if they do laugh at you,
you know what?
It doesn't matter because when you take the test,
you're going to do better.
So don't be embarrassed to ask questions,
ask questions and study hard.
Next,
what mental challenges did you face training to be a navy seal?
Well,
there's all kinds of challenges that you faced trying to become a navy seal.
And
I'm trying to think of my personal ones.
Well,
there's a bunch.
And the biggest thing for me is I wasn't great at anything.
I wasn't the fastest runner.
I wasn't the fastest swimmer.
I wasn't fastest at the obstacle course.
I wasn't the best shot with a pistol,
a rifle.
So everything for me was hard and I had to work hard at everything that I did.
And so for me there was never a mental rest.
Some guys,
they might not be the best runner,
but there a great swimmer.
So during the swim it was kind of easy for him.
I didn't really have any breaks,
so that was probably my biggest mental challenge.
Yeah.
Next is from a reader.
How am I supposed to stop missing one of my friends that live really far away
and we've been friends for over five years.
Okay,
well when you miss one of your friends,
the best thing to do is write to them,
write them letters,
call them if you can write them emails.
I keep in touch with them and it's no,
it's,
it's normal to miss your friends when they leave,
so you shouldn't even try and stop missing them.
Just write them letters,
tell him what's going on and maintain contact with them.
Next
uncle.
Dear Uncle Jake,
you are so wise.
You were the only person who knows the answer to this question.
How do I stop eating junk food?
I can't stop.
Help me.
So actually the only person that can stop you from eating junk food isn't uncle
Jake.
It's you.
You're the one that has to stop eating junk food and the way you do it isn't as
hard as you think.
Actually,
it's simple.
It's not easy,
but it's simple.
The junk food that you want to put into your mouth,
don't put it into your mouth.
Don't do it.
You know it's weak food.
Like Echo said earlier,
it's weak food and we don't want to eat that week food.
We want the strong food.
So
when it,
when you get tempted to eat that week food,
don't do it.
Don't do it.
Don't take one bite.
Don't even say I'm just going to have one cookie instead of four.
Don't have any cause once you have one it's all no.
So
the way that you stopped from eating junk food is by stop eating junk food.
That's what you need to do
next.
Why did I write,
decided to write this story?
Cause I thought there was a lot of kids that could learn from it.
Even my own kids.
That's one of the main reasons I wrote it.
To have any other books coming out?
Yes.
May of 2018 hours have a book coming out.
It's more of an adult book coming out in October.
What's the favorite book I've written?
I already answered that one.
What have I ever been to mark situation when I was a child?
Yes.
Like I said,
of course it was hard.
I couldn't do a bunch of pull ups.
I was not one of the stronger kids.
I had trouble in school sometimes,
so every I,
I relate to everything that mark went through and I saw my own kids go through
those same troubles.
How can I stop eating so much junk food?
I already answered that.
Stop eating junk food.
How can I convince my parents to get a puppy?
Ooh.
Now if I could answer that question,
I'd probably be the most popular person in the world.
It's really hard because what kids don't realize is that puppies are a huge,
huge responsibility and it's,
I have had dogs a lot in my life and I have kids a lot in my life and I have
four kids.
Then I will tell you that the responsibility of a dog is almost as much as the
responsibility of having a kid.
So it's not really easy to get a to own a dog.
So the best thing you can do,
I think if you want to convince your parents to let you get a puppy,
which is no guarantee,
the best thing you can do is be a good kid.
Work hard,
show responsibility,
get good grades in school,
help with the chores,
help with the cleaning up.
Because the bottom line is when you,
when you get a puppy,
there's one big issue with a puppy that no one wants to talk about.
And that's puppy Poopoo,
right?
What's going to happen?
Who's going to,
who's going to clean up the puppy Poopoo in the yard?
Is it going to be you because your parents don't think you're going to do it?
And that's one of the main reasons they don't want to get you a puppy because
they don't want to pick up puppy poopoo.
So show that you're responsible.
And how can I convince my parents to allow me to be on social media more than I
am now?
I would say your parents are doing a great job.
The social media is not going to help you and don't try and convince them of
that work on the puppy instead,
that's going to be better for you.
Next,
my brother bullies me and makes me do everything for him and if not,
he says he will take something from me and hide it or hurt me.
Well,
do you got to negotiate with your older brother?
First of all,
he's running around being a bully.
That's not cool at all.
I would talk to your parents about it and say that you're being bullied and
tell,
tell your parents what's going on.
But I would also talk to your brother about it and say,
you know why you doing this to me?
Why are you treating me like this?
Do you think it's fun for me?
And if he doesn't seem to care,
well then you might have to go into some kind of guerrilla warfare against your
brother and start maybe if he wants you to do something for him,
maybe you don't do it perfectly,
do it a little bit less than perfect or maybe take a long time to do it.
And it's really hard.
It's really hard growing up in a,
in a house with older brothers and older sisters that bully you.
So talk to your parents about it and as always,
start doing a bunch of pullups.
Try and learn some Jujitsu.
Learned to stand up for yourself,
study hard,
and also the worst case scenario in this.
If you,
let's say that you can't stop your brother from bullying you because that's just
the way it is and your parents aren't around enough.
You know what you can do from this situation is you can learn from it.
You can learn from your brother by the way he mistreats you.
You can learn that you're never going to do that to other people and you're
never going to do that to other kids and that you're going to treat people much
better than your brother treats you.
So even if you can't stop him and he ends up pulling you until he moves out of
the house,
he's taught you such a valuable lesson about life and about human beings that
it'll be worth it in the long run.
So I know it's tough.
I know it's hard,
but learn as much as you can from it.
And in the meantime also take those steps so that you can stop him.
Good luck with that,
buddy.
That's a tough one.
Okay,
question one,
what is the meaning of life?
I guess that you are not playing around with any easy questions for uncle Jake,
uncle Jake,
Uncle Jake will tell you that the meaning of his life is to try and help other
people and try and do good in the world.
That's what he's trying to do with his life.
How do I stop my friend from laughing so much?
I would say if your friend is laughing so much,
I don't know why you'd want to stop them unless they're getting in trouble and
if they're getting in trouble,
just go sit in a seat that's not so close to them in class.
I had a friend named writer when I was a kid and he would have laughing attacks
and he would laugh so hard that he would get kicked out of the classroom.
And I remember one time he was laughing so hard,
he got kicked out of the classroom and after about five minutes went by,
I looked to the door where the window was.
There was a window in the door to the classroom and his face came up into the,
into the window and he was still laughing hysterically after five minutes.
So sometimes people laugh and,
and normally people laugh hard when you're not supposed to.
That's one of the things that makes laughing hard funny is you're not supposed
to be laughing.
So yeah,
just move away from him and tell him to calm down or else you can't hang out
with them during classes.
Okay.
Most pushups,
no.
Okay.
No matter how much stress I put on myself,
the most pushups I can do is 50 how do I improve?
Just keep doing pushups.
If you can do 50 right now,
do two or three sets of 50 and keep doing pushups.
That's how you get booted,
Betty.
Better at any of these things.
Can you join the navy at 12 years old?
No,
you can't join the navy until you turn 18
let's see.
How are we doing on time?
Oh,
I think we're going to make it.
I'm trying to keep this to an hour everybody cause I know I got what great
letter yesterday from a kid that rode,
said,
hey,
thanks for writing way the warrior kid and putting all the lessons in it that
you talk about on your podcast,
but we don't have to listen to your whole podcast,
which gets boring to learn the lessons.
So honesty.
Yes,
kids are always honest and that's,
well kids most of the time are honest.
What is the question on this one?
Yeah.
Was this book a kid and adult guide to becoming strong and healthy?
Because the books talks about things.
What mark needs to do to become smart and fit.
Yes,
that's exactly what the book was for.
The book was a guidebook for kids to become smarter,
stronger,
faster,
and better people.
That's,
that's what the book is about.
And also,
I wish I would've had this book when I was a kid.
Let's see,
I have a question about the book.
I always fight with my brother.
What should I do?
Well,
that's,
that's a tough one because kids fight with their siblings.
I had two sisters growing up and we got in fights all the time.
And I wish I could go back and be more mature because I was,
you know,
a kid.
And when you look back,
you say,
what was I doing fighting with my two sisters?
That's ridiculous.
So what you need to do is look at the things I,
this is,
this is one thing you can do to start with,
look at the things you're fighting about.
And I can pretty much guarantee that the things you're fighting about are the
most silly and ridiculous things.
Right?
Like what,
what piece of carrot do you get?
I want this carrot.
No,
I want that carrot.
And then you're fighting about it.
What were you going to put your head on the couch?
Don't put your head in near me.
Don't put your foot in near me.
Right?
That's the kind of things that kids fight about.
So what we have to do is instead of letting those things annoy,
you,
just say,
ah,
you know what?
He's gonna put his head over here.
I'm just gonna move my head a little bit.
There's a great a war hero that we had that I talked to named uh,
Captain Charlie Plumb.
And he was in the Vietnam War.
He was a fighter pilot in the Vietnam War and he was shot down and he was held
in a prison camp for six years.
And one of the things that he said,
if you can imagine,
you know,
you,
you think it's hard living with your brother because you have to spend,
you know,
a couple hours a day in the same house.
Imagine being in a little tiny prison cell for six years with other people day
in,
day out,
24 hours a day.
So what they figured out was if they got mad or they got annoyed at something
someone else was doing,
they didn't blame the other person.
They blamed themselves.
So if you don't want to fight with your brother,
stop blaming him for being annoying and start blaming yourself for getting
annoyed and just try and be a little bit more mature about it.
Next,
I enjoyed your book.
I'm going to medical middle school and I don't want to lose touch with people.
Hey,
if you're a,
this happens when kids move around,
just get out,
get their address and start writing letters.
That's what you need to do.
Let's see.
How do you improve and pull ups?
Do pull ups,
how do you improve and running?
Run?
How do you overcome your fears?
Talked about that one.
You train,
you practice and then you face them.
And water healthy foods other than milk.
I think the key thing with healthy foods is to eat things that are made by
nature,
not by man.
So if it comes in a big plastic package in a box,
and it had,
and when you look at the list of ingredients,
it's a 147 words that you can't pronounce.
That's the thing you got to watch out for.
But if it's a carrot or it's an orange or it's a steak or it's a piece of
chicken and the ingredients and the chicken or chicken and the ingredients in
the stake,
our stake and the ingredients and the fishes,
fish and ingredients in the,
in the lettuces,
lettuce,
those are the things you want to try and eat.
Those are the healthiest things.
Major question for Uncle Jake.
Need more money for fidget spinners and a May merge Paki and Roebucks,
but my parents won't let me have money for it.
What should I do?
Really easy.
Get a job.
That's what you do when you need money,
you get a job,
you don't get things for free.
You have to work.
So if you need money for all these ridiculous things that you want to spend it
on,
which by the way,
they're all ridiculous.
You should save your money for some things like pull up bars or just save your
money for your future.
Save it for when you go to college,
but you're not going to get million.
Your parents aren't obligated to give you money for junk,
which is what you want it for.
Your parents are actually smart for not giving you money.
I wouldn't give you money to buy that junk.
So if you want money,
get a job mowing lawns,
pulling out weeds,
throwing newspapers,
whatever it is you've got to do.
But if you want to buy junk,
you've got to do with your own money,
not your parents.
Next question,
if someone's too lazy to get up in the morning and doesn't get,
want to get woken up by someone who is smashing utensils or anything in your
eardrum,
what does a more easier way to get up?
What is an easier way to get up and you are talking about yourself.
That's from our well what you need to do in those situations.
It's getting alarm clock and when the alarm clock goes off,
get up and get out of bed,
and if you still feel tired in the morning,
then you need to go to bed earlier at night.
Okay?
So it's never easy to get up in the morning.
Get up.
Getting up in the morning is hard.
That's why it's such an edge over normal people,
because normal people,
when they want to sleep,
they want to sleep and sleep and sleep.
And when you sleep,
you're not being productive.
Now of course you need sleep.
It's good for you to sleep.
You're going to be stronger.
The more you sleep,
the stronger you're going to be.
But if you sleep and you don't work out and you sleep and you'd miss your
schoolwork and you sleep and you're just being lazy,
that's not going to be good for you.
So get an alarm clock set,
alarm clock.
When your alarm clock goes off,
get up and get out of bed.
How do I stop eating food that's not healthy?
You stop eating the food that's not healthy.
That's it.
Also,
tell your mom another thing.
For those of you who to ask you this question until your mom and dad not to buy
that food.
You don't want it in the house.
That's what you need to do.
Tell your parents you don't want the ice cream in the house.
You don't want the Cheetos in the house.
You don't want the,
what's another good one?
Echo what?
You don't want the chocolate chip cookies in the house.
Now if you're out and you just had a nice,
you know at a ball game and you play to baseball or you played a soccer game or
a football game and your mom's stops it up,
shop on the way home and says,
hey son,
you played a great game.
You want a chocolate chip cookie?
And you go,
yeah,
that sounds good.
Little reward.
That's okay,
that's great.
But if you have those chocolate chip cookies in your house and you just got done
playing two hours worth of video games and you're feeling a little bit hungry,
so you go in the kitchen,
there's a chocolate chip cookie box and you eat nine of them,
that's not good.
So don't do that.
Or Soda or they have soda is horrible.
You shouldn't,
you should beg your parents not to bring soda in the House.
If you're,
if your parents bring soda in the house,
you should say,
oh do you not like me cause why are you feeding me this?
This is poison.
Don't feed me poison.
I want water.
Just bring me some water.
Mom and dad please.
Let's see
how to start a good habit such as working out your start working out.
Okay.
Next.
How old was uncle Jake when he joined the seal teams?
He was 18 can you join at 10 years old?
No.
How was Uncle Jake?
Six periods in the seal teams.
He loved it all.
Uncle Jake,
I have a question for you.
How do you get stronger and not get bullied?
Rd answered that one.
You work out,
you trained,
you Jitsu,
you trained boxing,
you train wrestling,
you're trained judo and you stand up to those bullies.
Like I said,
not always going to win,
but you'll win in the long run.
Five year old wants to know why you have to do pull ups to be a warrior kid.
You don't have to do pull ups to be a warrior kid,
but pull ups is a great exercise.
Like there's some people that maybe they have some issue with that maybe they
got a hurt shoulder or a hurt arm and they can't do pullups and that's okay.
You can still be a warrior kid,
but if you,
if your arms are healthy and you can do pull ups,
they're great thing to do because it means you can handle your own weight.
It means you can carry yourself.
It means you can take care of yourself.
So that's why pull ups are great,
a great exercise and they're also,
I've read a lot of stuff that if kids can do pull ups,
it,
it helps their overall health.
So cloves are great for you.
It's a great exercise if you can do them,
do them.
If you're injured or you've got some kind of an issue where you can't do them,
try and find a different exercise that you can do and focus on that one.
Next question's from six year old boy
McGee.
Is Uncle Jake Real?
No.
Uncle Jake is a fictional character.
How old is Uncle Jake?
Uncle Jake in the book is,
I think about 26 years old.
And what keeps uncle Jake moving during really hard times when the going gets
tough for Uncle Jake?
You know what Uncle Jake does?
He actually enjoys it.
He knows he's being challenged and so he pushes himself
next.
When you're working out
and feeling under the weather,
should you still give 100% well,
actually,
if you're feeling sick,
maybe it's time for a little rest.
If you just don't feel 100% like maybe you're feeling a little tired,
a little mopey that day,
still get in there and you're not gonna be able to give 100% everyday.
No one can give 100% every day.
You'll run out of percent.
So you've got to save some of that percent.
So you can't give 100% every day,
but give what you can do to,
you can't get in there and make it happen.
How is Uncle Jake doing in college?
Uncle Jake is doing outstanding in college.
Did Uncle Jake respond to Mark's letter?
Yes,
he did.
And what was the response you'll find out in May when the next book comes out?
How uncle Jake's knows so many languages.
And how does he know the Warrior Code in the book?
Uncle Jake studies languages.
When you're,
when you're in the military and you go to other countries,
a lot of times you'll study the language that they speak there so you can
communicate with the local people.
So that's how uncle Jake knows a little bit of a lot of different languages.
And how does he know the warrior codes in the book he studies and reads about
the past and reads about history and reads about what other warriors were like
so that he can figure out what they did well so he can do the same thing.
How many pull ups can uncle Jake do?
Uncle Jake can do 75 pull ups.
Has Uncle Jake ever jumped off a bridge into a lake before?
Many times.
What was your job in the kneel in the navy seals.
And what team were you on?
Well,
this is Jocko and Jocko.
I was on my job.
I started off as a radio man,
which I meant I carried the radio and then I became an officer,
which means I would be in charge of a seal squad or a seal platoon or a seal
task unit.
And then the seal teams I was on,
I was on seal team one seal team to seal team three and seal team seven.
Question from warrior kid Aiden,
what kind of would you recommend for 12 year old boy to get stronger push ups,
pull ups,
sit ups,
squats and I would do a lot of those,
like I said,
eight to 10 sets and,
and that's what you build up to when you first start.
You might only be able to do three or four sets and then sometimes you do one
day you do pullups eight sets of Poles the next day do pushups,
eight sets of pushups the next day do squats,
eight sets of squats and just keep working.
Next,
what is the middle name?
Uncle Jake's middle name.
You're gonna have to find that one out in the second book.
And what was it like to be in the navy?
Seals being in the seal teams is so fun and it was a great job and I loved every
second of it.
And Uncle Jake loved the seal teams as well and it's also a dangerous job.
So a lot of people think that they want to join the seal teams because it's a
lot of fun and it looks cool and you get to do cool stuff,
but you also got to remember it's a very dangerous job.
And being uh,
being in the seal teams isn't just fun all the time.
It's hard work,
very hard work and it's a very dangerous sometimes.
So if it's something that a lot of a lot of kids have been asking about,
how do,
what do I do to get ready for the seal teams?
You need to make sure that you have the right attitude about danger because it's
a very dangerous job sometimes,
but it's also a lot of fun.
We'll uncle Jake come back to mentor mark in his teenage years.
Yes he will.
He's going to mentor him for about six bucks until he's done with his high
school career.
Let's see,
Nolan and Brady ask,
how are you so smart?
Well,
I'm not that smart.
Uncle Jake is very smart,
but the way you get smarter by reading,
that's the,
to me that's one of the most important reading and studying.
That's how you get smart.
So read and study as much as you can and find books that you're interested in.
I read a lot of books about war cause I'm very interested in war,
but those are the,
those are the kinds of books that I'm interested in and there's a lot of books
about that.
But anything that you're interested in,
if you're interested in cars,
read about cars and how they work.
If you're interested in computers,
read about how computers work.
If you're interested in space,
travel,
read books about space travel.
But the more you read,
the smarter you're going to be.
Let's see.
How can I get my little brother more interested in the story and reading the
book if he doesn't like reading that much,
read it to them.
Sit Down with them and read it to him.
Yeah.
Five-Year-Old,
a question here.
What should I do in my friends?
Don't want to play with me at school.
I say you play by yourself.
I say you go over and find the pull up bar and find the swing set and do things
that you can just do by herself.
And every once in a while go over and see what they're doing and ask them about
it and see if you know,
if they need anyone else to play with them.
And if they don't,
then that's fine.
Like I said,
it's,
it's okay to be alone sometimes and sometimes kids you don't.
One of the hardest things,
one of the,
another reason why I wrote this book is that being a kid is hard and kids can be
really mean.
And when I was a kid,
I felt both sides of that.
Sometimes I had kids be mean to me and sometimes I was meeting the other kids,
like I said,
because I was immature and I didn't know.
So the older I got,
the nicer you can be.
But sometimes when you're,
you know,
six and seven and eight years old,
sometimes kids can be really mean.
And that doesn't mean you should be mean.
In fact what it means.
You should be nice,
so if you've got kids that don't want to play with you,
that's okay.
Spend some time by herself.
Look for some other kids that maybe do want to hang out a little bit.
What do you do on a daily basis as a navy seal?
It's really hard to describe what you do as a navy seal on a daily basis because
it changes every day.
Sometimes you're parachuting,
sometimes you're shooting guns.
Sometimes you're blowing things up.
Sometimes you're working out,
sometimes you're doing paperwork,
sometimes you're traveling.
Sometimes you're going on a long patrols,
which is like a hike through the desert or through the jungle or through the
mountains.
Sometimes you're in the water doing diving.
Sometimes you're,
it's just a very,
it's very hard to describe what you do every single day because it's different
every day and that's one of the things that makes the job very exciting and fun.
They said you get to do different stuff all the time.
What tips and tricks would you have for getting up and getting after it?
When I'm not feeling it.
That's from Gavin.
I think that was a,
that was a video one Gavin said,
and he's not feeling it.
Sometimes those are the special days where you actually have to do it,
so the days when you're not feeling it are the days where you get better.
The days that you don't want to study,
those are the days you get smarter.
The days that you don't want to work out,
but you can work out anyways.
Those are the days you get stronger,
so when you're not feeling it,
tell yourself,
Ooh,
good.
It's an opportunity for me to step up,
overcome some weakness and get better.
What made uncle Jake and Jocko want to be a navy seal?
Like I said,
I always wanted to be a commando.
Kids in class want to know what Jake's purposes for going to college,
what's his new goal?
Well,
Uncle Jake has been an enlisted guy in the seal teams and he wants to become an
officer.
He wants to move into more of a leadership role,
and so what he's going to do is he's going to go to college,
he's going to get his degree,
and then he's hopefully going to go back to the seal teams as an officer so he
can be in charge of a seal platoon.
That's one of his goals.
The inspiration for mark,
like I said,
was Mark Lee,
and that's who he's named after.
But also mark represents all kinds of kids,
even myself and my own kids is,
you know,
it's like I said,
it's hard being a kid.
So mark is a representation of some of the struggles that kids face,
and then the struggles aren't going to be the exact same,
right?
Some kids might be good at math,
but they're not good at spelling.
Some kids might be good at math and spelling,
but they can't any history facts.
So your challenges are going to be different.
Some kids might be good at pull ups,
but they're not fast runners.
Some kids might be fast runners,
but they're not good at throwing a baseball.
So the challenges are different.
But how you overcome those challenges are the same and that's through hard work
and practice.
So that was the inspiration.
And like I said,
the Uncle Jake to me was always in my mind just the,
the ultimate seal.
And that's what I tried to make him to be like.
And Mark was an average kid that's going to do above average things,
through hard work and through discipline.
And so those are the questions that we had for this podcast and appreciate all
those questions that everyone sent me.
I know it's,
um,
a lot of stuff out there and I know that it's,
it was hard for me to go through them all,
but I was really thankful that we got all those questions and I'm sure we'll
have some more questions in the future.
Thanks for reading the book.
Thanks for showing all those cool pictures of everyone out there reading the
book and doing their timestables and studying and using flashcards and doing
pull ups.
That's great for me to see.
And like I said,
I liked seeing kids do things where they're getting better.
So thanks for reading the book and,
and telling your friends about the book.
I appreciate it.
And most of all,
thanks for training hard.
Thanks for studying hard and thanks for working hard to get stronger,
smarter,
faster,
and better.
So stay on the path of discipline and keep getting after it.
Until next time from Uncle Jake and echo and Jocko out.